- And if you ignore everything else,
this is the one where you
stop and you pay attention.
Because this could save
years of your life.
It is so easy to get lost
in the day-to-day grind
of what you do, what any of us do.
Letting other people
come in and degrade what
you think of yourself is
one of the most dangerous
and damning things that you could do.
- Need motivation?
- Watch The Top 10 with Believe Nation.
- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is believe and
this channel is designed
to be a part of your
daily success routine.
So let's get your motivation to a 10
and get you believing in you.
Grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a
man who went from growing
up in a morbidly obese
family, being dead broke
and unable to pay his bills,
to building a billion dollar company
and now dedicating his life
to pulling people out
of the matrix and having
one YouTube channel that
is among my favorites.
He's Tom Bilyeu and here's my take on his
Top 10 Rules for Success, Volume Seven.
Also if you want to
know what Tom and other
successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building
unstoppable confidence,
check out my 254 confidence
series where, everyday, for
the next 254 days I will
send you a free morning short video
to help build your confidence.
The link to join is in
the description below.
- There's a gap between who
people are, and what they
tell you they want to accomplish.
- Okay, let's kick it
off with Rule Number One:
Don't Let Obstacles Break You.
- As Confucius said, "When it's obvious
"that the goal cannot be reached,
"don't adjust the goals,
adjust the action steps."
That may be the single best
piece of advice you're ever
going to get.
Write that down.
Burn it into your flesh.
Tattoo it on your soul.
Do whatever you need to do
to remember that once you
set a goal, once you've
decided in your life, there
is something that you're
going to make come true,
don't let anything stop
you from reaching that.
But the reality is as you
go things are going to get in your way.
There will be an inevitable
slew of obstacles coming at you.
But when it gets so hard
that you realize that the
path that you're on simply
is not going to take you
where you want to go,
rather than give up on what
it was you said you were going
to do, find a different path.
And in that when you really make that
the cornerstone of your
identity, that you refuse to bend
or be broken by obstacles,
by challenges, but instead
you rise to those challenges,
you go over, under,
through them, you do whatever you have to
you devise any plan to find a way through,
then your life will change.
Once that becomes your
reaction to not change that
thing that meant so much to you,
that you've dedicated your life
to making it come true,
that you don't change that
but rather you find another
way, you tap into your
creativity, you find
somebody that can help you,
you do whatever it takes
to get on the other side
of that, you do whatever
it takes to build that life
that you want to see.
But if your reaction
is to change your goal, to make it easier,
to move it closer, to be
less of who you could be,
simply so you could check a box.
You're never going to have
anything that's worth having.
- Rule Number Two:
Take the First Step.
- Why, like if you had to boil it down,
why do most people fail?
Got it locked?
The answer is they never start.
Now the reason that
most people never start
is because they don't
think they're going to get
a result from their actions
and then that's going
to come down to a belief that
they believe about themselves.
"I'm too stupid."
"I'm not good enough."
"I don't have the natural talent."
"I wasn't born at the right time
"or in the right neighborhood."
"My parent's didn't teach me that"
That's why most people fail.
There's a great quote
by Amelia Earhart, I'll paraphrase.
The hard thing is taking the first step,
everything else is just persistence.
And I've always loved that
quote because it's so true.
It doesn't mean that you're
going to get it right,
it doesn't mean that
just because you start
you're going to win.
In fact, most likely,
the first thing you do,
you're going to fail.
Speak about all the times
that you tried something
and it failed.
The first time when you tried to get
the business going and it didn't work.
Or the first house you
tried to sell and nobody
went for it, or the first
time that you lost money.
And the question is, what did you do then?
If you learned from it,
doubled down, figured it out
focused only on the truth,
then you moved forward.
You move forward because
you believe you can learn
And that's that thing, hiding in that,
and this is the thing when
people ask me, hey my mom
or my wife or whatever, they
don't have that belief system.
They don't have what Carol
Dweck calls a growth mindset.
How do I get them there?
The answer is you don't.
Until they are convinced
that they can learn anything
that they put their mind to,
that their energy is doubled down into
that area of gaining skills
will actually pay off.
With a real world ability
to do something new,
they're not going to act.
- Rule Number Three:
Out-work Everyone.
- Coby Bryant, one of the
greatest athletes of our
time, would show up on game
day and if he saw anybody
else at the gym as early
as him, even though he was
always the first on the court,
he would end up practicing
longer than that person.
And I had the honor
of interviewing one of
those people one time.
And he said, "I went up and
asked Coby, Coby we have
"a game in an hour, like
what are you doing out here
"practicing so long?"
And Coby said "I needed you to know
"that I was willing to out-work you."
And in that game they
ended up winning, and that
lesson stuck with that guy forever.
When you're willing to put in the work,
when you're willing to take control of
your environment and
put yourself through the
stressors required for
adaptation, you literally
can become anything.
And my life is proof of that.
- Rule number Four:
Prepare for the Luck.
- I hear people talk about luck a lot.
And I know that people
think about the role
that luck plays in their life.
But the reality is, luck is all around,
luck is ever present.
Luck literally is coming to you every day,
it's passing you by.
It's happening to you right now.
But the question is, are you able
to take advantage of the luck?
Have you prepared for the luck?
And I think that it comes down to,
we have a misconception
about what luck is.
We think of luck as
something being passive,
that we sit, we wait,
we're in some obscure place
and still somehow the luck find us.
But the reality is we're awash in luck.
What we're missing is the
ability to make use of it.
If you have a bunch of bullets but no gun
you really have nothing.
If you have a gun but no
bullets, the same thing.
The magic moment comes
together when you have
two things that work
in conjunction and you have them both.
You can't have luck without the diligence.
You can't have success without the skills.
You've got to spend your life preparing
to capitalize on that luck.
And to look at what
somebody has done, to look
at a moment of success
in their life and to say that it was luck,
is to create a frame of reference
for you in which you can't
see how you yourself could
leverage what you have
to get lucky.
- Rule Number Five:
Find Deep Fulfillment.
- One thing I want to make really clear.
And if you ignore everything
else, this is the one
where you stop and pay attention.
Because this could save
years of your life.
The game you're playing is not success,
the game you're playing is not money,
the game you're playing
is brain chemistry.
The only thing that
matters in life, truly,
the only thing that matters in life,
is what you think about
yourself when you're
by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts.
If in that moment you feel
good about who you are,
who you're becoming,
what you're capable of,
and what you're willing
to do to make a better
future for yourself, those
you care about and other
people around you, you
will love your life.
It is the single most
pleasurable neuro-chemical
state is deep fulfillment.
Okay?
Not happiness.
A bowl of ice cream brings me a lot
of happiness, but it is a
very transient experience.
Deep and lasting fulfillment matters.
And what that comes down
to is how you feel about
yourself when you're by yourself.
- Rule Number Six:
Know Your Why.
- The piece of advice that
I always give to somebody,
whether it's an entrepreneur
or somebody who wants
to be the greatest parent of all time.
What is your goal?
You've got to start with your goal.
Everything works backwards from that.
Simon and I did a video
that essentially broke
the Internet about millennials.
Somebody watched it.
(audience members laugh)
What got Simon on the
world stage is his whole
concept of why?.
You've got to know why you're
doing what you're doing.
If you're just showing up
every day to cut and
dye hair, to keep your
lights on, you're going
to have far less energy
to make it through the
hard times than somebody
who is there to help transform somebody,
to make somebody their best,
to help them feel their best.
And I hope that you guys saw that
video not too long ago
of the hairdresser that
went around and he was doing
makeovers on homeless people.
(audience claps)
Right?
Man, it was incredible.
It was so beautiful,
the look on their face
at that moment when they
see themselves for the first
time in front of the
mirror and they are seeing
something totally new.
They are seeing a version
of themselves that they
did not know was there.
And the ability to give
that gift, like it is so
easy to get lost in the
day-to-day grind of what
you do, what any of us
do, but if at the core
driving you is a deep and unending why
for what you're doing,
you've got something.
Now you've got a chance to
transcend what you're doing.
And the way that happens is very tactical,
it has nothing to do with
being woo-woo being out there.
It's none of that.
You're going to have the energy
that you need to fight through.
- Rule Number Seven:
Protect Your Vision.
- We get to decide who we are.
There's no objective truth
that you're going to find or uncover.
You are simply the collection
of the things you believe
to be true about yourself.
And once you begin to form that opinion
of who you are, you'll act in
accordance with that belief.
You begin to shape a vision of yourself
in your own mind and
that becomes the reality.
So letting other people influence that,
letting other people
come in and degrade what
you think of yourself, is
one of the most dangerous
and damning things you could do.
Because they cloud your ability to craft.
To craft a vision of the
person that you want to become.
And that vision is so hard for all
of us to hold on to that
we have to protect it.
We have to keep other people out of that.
We've got to have intention in creating
the person that we want to become.
- Rule Number Eight:
Get Better.
- You are all hopelessly average by birth.
We all are.
And that's the great news.
Because the most important
thing to understand
about the human species
we are the ultimate adaptation machine.
If you guys were paying attention
not too long ago they
sequenced the human genome
and they realized that the
human genome has 20,000 genes.
And everybody they thought
that they were going to cure
cancer, all the diseases,
AIDS related disease, everything,
Type 1, Type 2 diabetes.
It was all going to be
a thing of the past.
We were going to have it figured out.
And then we realized that
an onion has more genetic
diversity than we do.
And how could that be?
And so they're literally going,
is this really possible?
Did we misunderstand something?
How is it that an onion
has more genetic diversity
than we have?
And somebody finally said,
hey maybe all this stuff
that we've been referring
to as junk DNA, maybe it
actually plays a role.
And then they began to
realize that all that
junk DNA that was outside
of those 20,000 genes
that we saw expressing themselves,
is what is called epigenetics.
Now if you've ever heard
of epigenetics that's
amazing, you're way ahead.
If you haven't heard of epigenetics,
let it become one of the
most important things
in your life because
epigenetics is what has made
us the most dominant species
this planet has ever seen.
It is the only thing
that you need to know.
It's what I call the
only belief that matters.
The only belief that matters
is that you can learn anything.
I don't need you to believe
that you're good now.
That doesn't matter.
Who you are now is totally irrelevant.
The only thing I want to
know, who are you willing
to become and what's
the price you're willing
to pay to get there?
And that's what humans are designed to do.
If you put us under stress,
we can learn something new.
We can get better.
- Rule Number Nine:
Turn Negatives Into Positives.
- "What are some ways that I can stop
"giving this negative feedback to myself?"
Okay so, first of all
you've got to train yourself
to use the negative
thoughts that you have as a
habit loop trigger of something positive.
That's the first step to all of this.
So I don't think anybody
is going to be able
to get rid of the negative
voice, and even if you
could I actually don't
think you would want to.
I think the reality is you
want to use that as your
jujitsu flip to get
over to the positive way
of thinking, to get into
that positive habit loop.
To remind yourself that even if you're not
good at it yet, you can get good at it.
That you're going to learn
by whatever you're doing.
- And Rule Number 10, the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is Build the Life You Want.
- I don't think people really realize
we construct our lives.
We build them from nothing.
We decide what our goals are.
We decide what way to move.
We decide who we're
going to become and
what we're going to get.
But it's a decision, it's a process.
It isn't something that
somebody hands to you.
And so, if you find that
your life is a misery
understand that your life
is an exact reflection
of your choices.
And if you want a different life
you need only make a different choice.
But I know right now
many of you are thinking
"But I don't know what way to go.
I don't know what choice to make.
I don't know what it is
that I want to do.
As as Roy Maurice Keane said,
"I don't believe skill
was or ever will be the
"result of coaches.
"It is a result of a love affair
"between the child and the ball."
So ask yourself:
what's that thing that you love?
And don't judge yourself
if it was something you
loved as a child that
people are telling you
you couldn't make money
at, and it's that part
of the equation that I
want to break for people.
I want you to understand,
stop asking yourself
what you can make a lot
of money at and start
asking yourself, what would you enjoy?
What is that life that you
don't need to escape from?
What is the life that is your love?
What is the thing that
as a kid you did whether
people wanted you to or not?
What is the thing you
would sneak out at night
to do because you weren't
going to be stopped from doing it?
Everybody has something
like that in their life.
Some spark of interest,
maybe long dormant.
Maybe they've pushed
aside because they think
it's stupid.
Or maybe they failed once.
And they think they're bad at it.
Even though they love it,
that sting of the failure
has convinced them to stop pursuing it.
But at the end of the day, the only thing
that matters is what
gives you that energy.
At the end of the day,
the thing that matters is
what fills you with joy.
At the end of the day,
the only thing that matters is not success
and sure as hell isn't money.
It's how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself.
It's the things that give you energy.
It's what you think about yourself.
It's how you react to the hard things.
It's whether or not you push through.
And when you push through,
when you persevere,
when you go down the
process of taking the time
to structure your life,
to build it into something
you want it to be, to
build it into something
you're proud of, to
become the person that's
capable of the things you want to do,
that can first fall in love
with something and do it for
the love of it, not worry
about what other people think.
If you hate your life I guarantee
the thing is you are trapped
by what other people think.
You don't want to give it
up because somebody will
think you're a failure,
you don't want to give
it up because it's a paycheck.
You don't want to give it
up because you're scared.
You're scared you don't
know what you'll do next.
But imagine a world where
for a second all you
thought about was what do you love?
What do you enjoy in that moment?
It doesn't matter if it
changes from day to day.
What do you love?
What fills you with joy?
What gives you that energy?
At the end of the day
the only thing that we
all have is right now
this moment, it's what
you're experiencing.
Loving what you do, how
you spend your time.
That's the point of all of it.
The point of life is that.
In each transient moment
that passes by doing something
that fills you with joy.
Nobody can give you that.
You've got to build that life.
So go out.
Figure out what it is that you want to do
and brick by brick, have the courage to
build that life.
- Now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Tom on how to start
asking how your wrong,
that I think you're going to really enjoy.
But before that, it's
time for the three point
landing question, it's
time to move from just
watching another video
to actually taking action
in your life or in your business.
And if you're bold,
leave your replies in the comments below.
Here we go.
Question number one:
What is the first step that
you need to take today?
Number two:
What obstacle will you not
let break you?
And number three:
What are you going to
get better at this week?
- People get stuck.
They become so dogmatic.
They become so convinced
that they're right.
And that feeling of
being right gives them a
sense of self-worth.
And I'm telling you right
now, with compassion because
I want to see you win.
Valuing yourself for
being right is a trap.
Thinking of yourself as smart is a trap.
And I get it man, I know how good it feels
when you're right.
You had the right idea,
it goes out and it wins,
that feels so good.
But if you can recognize
that over time it can
only paint you into a
corner, because the world
changes, the world is adapting.
The very thing that
makes humans the ultimate
apex predator is that we adapt.
Charles Darwin said,
"It's not the strongest
"of the species that survive,
nor the most intelligent
"but rather the most adaptive to change."
You've got to be willing
to change, you've always
got to be willing to seek
out this confirming evidence.
You've got to hunger for it, you've got
to want to be proven wrong.
You've got to literally
invite people into your
world that are going
to point out flaws in
your thinking because
your thinking has already taken
you as far as it's going to.
So if you want to get farther,
if you want to get to that next level,
you've got to stop valuing yourself
for who you are, what you
think, how smart you are,
when you're right, when you're wrong,
all of that is irrelevant.
You've got to value
yourself entirely on your willingness
to admit that you're wrong.
You've got to value
yourself on your willingness to learn.
yourself on your willingness
to sit humbly at somebody's
feet and seek their wisdom.
To not try to be the hero.
But instead to try and be the one
that collects the knowledge.
When you can flip over into that
when you can value
yourself for a willingness
to stare nakedly at your own inadequacies,
you'll start to make progress in life.
But no matter how far you've got,
no matter how much you want,
no matter how certain you are,
no matter how much the things you've done
in your life have proven to be correct,
as Charlie Munger says,
"You must force yourself
to consider arguments
"on the other side."
You can always reject them,
you can always look at
it, really think about it
and say, "At the end of the
day, it's just not correct".
But when you are trying to hold
onto your ideas simply
because they're your ideas
or simply because they worked in the past
or simply because you like them,
you will fall into a
trap of dogma and you'll
no longer be able to
see fresh ideas and move
in new directions.
But if you're willing to acknowledge
that this world is constantly moving,
it's ever-changing.
The only thing true about the future,
always and forever, is that things change
and if you're thinking doesn't change,
you'll never be able to keep up.
So if you want to do
something extraordinary
with your life step number one,
always seek out that
disconfirming evidence
always look at arguments
from the other side.
If you are able to do
that, then you'll always
be able to stay ahead of the curve
and aging won't be a problem
because you'll stay fresh
in your mind.
You become invincible when you
bend and not break and
that's what this kind
of mindset will allow you to have.
So if you want to win,
stop thinking about how
you're right and start
asking how you're wrong.
- Raise your standards.
- Apple, at the core,
it's core value, is that
we believe that people
with passion can change
the world for the better.
- Not one drop of my self-worth depends
on your acceptance of me.
- If you liked this video
and want to learn more
about the power of habit check out
the video right next to me.
I think you're going to enjoy it.
Continue to believe
and I'll see you there.
- We are what we repeatedly do.
- Change doesn't just happen
at this level of behavior.
But you have to change the environment.
- Make a damn schedule!